My name is Rose George,
and I'm an author and journalist
and I'm fascinated by blood,
and here's why.
We are stardust and seawater.
The iron in our blood comes from
the death of supernovas -
like all iron on our planet -
and it contains salt and water,
like the oceans we came from.
The circulatory system of veins,
arteries, and capillaries
is about 100,000 kilometres long -
twice the circumference of the Earth.
Most of that is the capillaries -
tiny blood vessels and hollow ways
that reach nearly every cell
in the body.
You may know that your blood is...
but there are other types you
might not have heard of -
including
and the epically named...
Animals have blood types too,
dogs have eight,
cats have three.
When humans first tried to transfer
blood between bodies,
they used the blood
of a lamb and a calf.
Now, we stick to carefully chosen
human blood.
Blood transfusion is so common,
every three seconds worldwide
someone receives a stranger's blood.
We don't have the same supply
sloshing around our veins
all our lives.
Our blood is in a constant state
of decay and renewal.
Red blood cells live in our
body for about 143 days.
Decanted into a blood bag,
they have a shelf life of between
35 and 49 days.
Blood lasts longer than milk,
but not as long as cheese.
In a resting human, the heart pumps a
litre of blood every 10 seconds,
and it beats on average
75 times a minute.
A blue whale's heart,
the size of a small car,
beats five times a minute,
and less on deep dives.
A shrew's, a thousand times a minute.
The average human contains
eight to twelve pints of blood,
but can usually survive
losing up to 40%.
After that point,
the organs begin to shut down
because they are not being fed
oxygen by blood.
Blood has always been
thought powerful.
The mythical figure of Medusa
symbolised human
fear and awe of blood.
Blood from the right side
of her body was fatal,
while that from the left side
could restore life.
We may not believe
in Greek myths anymore,
but the force of blood
remains in language.
Blood is essential for human life,
but there is plenty we don't know
about this exceptional substance.
Scientists can now grow
red blood cells in the lab,
but they are extremely expensive.
For now, the only way to get this
life-saving, life-enhancing liquid
is out of the goodness
of someone's heart,
and the veins in their arm.